bonjour à tous
avant tout nous souhaitions lydia et moi
au nom des républicains souhaiter à
chacun de vous tous ceux qui sont
évidemment présents dans la salle
comme à tous ceux qui nous regardent une
excellente année 2010 8 d'abord titre
personnel pour vous même ainsi que pour
vos proches mais aussi pour la
démocratie parce que nous considérons
que cette année 2018 qui marquera le
retour de la droite à l'issue de
l'élection de laurent wauquiez à la tête
des républicains doit être une année de
production d'idées nouvelles de
confrontation d'idées de débat sur les
valeurs afin que emmanuel macron n'est
plus le monopole 20 que que parlons
l'extrémisme n'est plus le monopole de
l'opposition dans notre pays
nous avons considéré en élisant laurent
wauquiez qu'il était sain qu'une droite
républicaine puisse ressurgir dans le
débat public et que jean luc mélenchon
et marine le pen n'est plus le monopole
de l'opposition comme cela a pu sembler
être le cas lors de la deuxième partie
de l'année 2010 est indépendamment de
ses voeux nous avons considéré que
plusieurs événements récents exiger de
notre part une prise de position à
commencer évidemment par hier le triste
anniversaire des attentats de charlie
hebdo du 7 janvier 2015
effectivement hier ce fut la journée de
commémoration des attentats de charlie
hebdo qui rappelons le ont donné suite à
l'attentât de l'hyper cacher et à
l'assassinât également de clarissa
jean-philippe à à montrouge donc nous
souhaitons avoir une pensée pour toutes
les victimes de ces attentats
trois ans déjà trois ans que la liberté
d'expression est attaqué la laïcité des
journalistes des policiers ont perdu la
vie également il y a trois ans et des
juifs parce qu'ils étaient tout
simplement juifs en trois ans quels sont
les quels sont les les avancées sur sur
ces thèmes je pense que manuel macron
est très décevant
la laïcité est attaqué il nous a
récemment parlé de radicalisation de la
laïcité la liberté d'expression a été
attaquée quand charlie hebdo a vu sa
rédaction a décimé et un contrôle sur
les faits que news qui en fait un
contrôle de la liberté d'expression est
en projet donc vraiment il ya une énorme
déception quand quant à l'action des
manuels macron ses silences et ses
ambiguïtés sur la lutte contre
l'islamisme radical qui tue qui est
encore présent dans notre pays sont
extrêmement dangereux que nous aurions
aimé entendre de la part du président
c'est une parole claire sur ces sujets
et manuel valls il a également appelé à
faire un discours très clair sur la
laïcité
sa manière de défendre la laïcité face
aux premiers perry pour la laïcité qui
est la montée en puissance de
l'islamisme radical en france et pour le
moment nous n'avons eu encore une fois
comme je vous le disais des silences et
de l'ambiguïté le gouvernement ne nous
rassure pas non plus sûr sur la laïcité
nous avons eu des paroles fortes de du
ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur blanc caire mais qui n'a pas
été suivi
des faits ni d'action il nous a parlé
sur la question du voile pour les mères
accompagnatrices de sorties scolaires de
convictions personnelles
or nous attendons non pas des
convictions personnelles de la part du
ministre de l'éducation nationale et des
actions concrètes comme remettre la
circulaire chatel pour pour protéger les
directeurs des établissements scolaires
et protéger ce sanctuaire du savoir que
doit être l'école publique et laïque
du côté de la ministre des droits de
l'égalité hommes femmes
il ya également une grande déception
malgré quelques quelques déclarations
qui permettent d'entretenir l'ambiguïté
du gouvernement philippe sueur sur cette
question rappelons que madame schiappa a
quand même déclaré que l'égalité homme
femme se faisait en fonction des
territoires
là dessus on peut avoir qu'une grande
crainte sur sur son engagement est ce
qu'il est sincère ou est-ce qu'il est
dictée par par l'agenda du président
nous avons un sérieux doute sur la
question donc voilà après après une
présidence hollande qui a été
extrêmement décevante sur sur ces
questions et qui est le nid du
communautarisme
nous sommes dans dans la présidence
macron qui oublient que l'islamisme
radical tu es que la laïcité protège et
qu'elle doit être aujourd'hui protégé et
tout doit être mis en oeuvre pour
préserver ce principe fondamental de
notre république
les victimes sont devenus des bourreaux
et leurs combats étaient anéantis par
tous ceux qui considèrent que la laïcité
se radicalise ou ou qu'il existe une
forme d'intégrisme de la laïcité
ces trahisons à fond que le président
jupiter se transforme d'une certaine
façon en judas les attentats de charlie
hebdo on
il ya eu deux victimes qui sont ahmed
mera b et clarissa jean philippe qui
étaient des représentants de l'autorité
c'était des représentants de la
république qu'il appartenait à la police
et les violences policières qui est un
véritable sujet aujourd'hui puisque la
police connaît quotidiennement des
violences pour rappel il ya 21
une vingtaine policiers et gendarmes qui
sont blessés tous les mois dans le cadre
de leurs opérations et plus de soixante
suicides par an chez les policiers les
gendarmes ces chiffres sont alarmants
ils décrivent la détresse des policiers
et des gendarmes
après champigny argenteuil ou aulnay
c'est pour ces policiers qui sont dans
une véritable détresse doivent être
entendus et soutenu par par le
gouvernement l'impunité qui domine dans
certains quartiers doit être doit être
brisé ce sentiment d'impunité doit être
brisé et pour cela nous nous appelons à
ce que à ce que les peines plancher soit
remise remise de manière effective et
que les moyens de la police augmente
je vais maintenant laisser geoffroy vous
en dire plus sur sur les peines
planchers merci lydia nous avons un
problème c'est qu'il existe aujourd'hui
dans le code pénal des circonstances
aggravantes
c'est à dire des peines qui pourraient
être prononcés par une grande partie des
tribunaux lorsque des policiers ou des
gendarmes sont attaqués mais ces peines
ne sont globalement pas prononcé c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous souhaitons
au sein des républicains le
rétablissement des peines planchers et
nous vous annonçons aujourd'hui le
lancement d'une pétition qui sera
officialisé dans les minutes qui
viennent auquel à laquelle le peut
participer peuvent participer tous ceux
qui le souhaitent sur le site des
républicains dont le premier signataire
est évidemment laurent wauquiez suivi
par l'ensemble des membres de l'équipe
dirigeants des républicains qui
appellent solennellement au
rétablissement des peines planchers
c'est à dire ces peines minimales
automatique qui avait été mise en place
par nicolas sarkozy en 2007 il y avait
été supprimée par françois hollande et
christiane taubira en 2014
alors bien sûr que il nous
été dit ou répondu opposé que tout cela
pourrait s'opposer au principe
d'individualisation des peines eh bien
nous considérons que le principe
d'individualisation des peines qui doit
rester
évidemment un principe ne peut pas être
absolue et vous savez d'ailleurs que
lorsque nicolas sarkozy avait mis en
place les peines plancher il existait
une possibilité pour les magistrats de
déroger à ces peines plancher en les
motivant de manière spéciale
nous considérons donc que l'argument de
l'individualisation des peines ne peut
pas être opposé à cette nécessité
absolue
aujourd'hui de mieux protéger pas
uniquement les policiers mais aussi les
gendarmes et plus globalement toutes les
personnes qui sont des représentantes de
l'autorité publique
la république et défier attaqué par des
images qui sont insupportables par des
faits qui ne sont absolument pas
tolérable c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons voulu réaliser cet acte fort
qui est celui d'appeler tous ceux qui
souhaitent à interpeller le gouvernement
par la signature de cette pétition des
républicains appelant au rétablissement
des peines planchers eux
on nous a aussi expliqué que lorsqu'elle
avait été mise en place par nicolas
sarkozy en 2007 elle n'avait pas produit
les effets escomptés
en réalité le problème c'est que les
peines planchers n'avait pas été exécuté
et appliqué comme il aurait fallu
qu'elle avait été prononcée de manière
totalement inégal selon les territoires
et qu'elle avait été surtout prononcé
pour les petits délits alors qu'il
fallait bien entendu les prononcer avant
tout pour les grands délits donc nous
considérons aujourd'hui que le
rétablissement des peines plancher est
devenu une nécessité absolue avant tout
bien évidemment pour protéger et envoyer
un signal de confiance à l'égard de tous
les dépositaires
de l'autorité publique et nous demandons
à ce que les peines soient prononcées
mais aussi et surtout exécuté il y a
aujourd'hui cent mille peines de prison
qui ne sont pas exécutées bien entendu
que le rétablissement des peines
planchers ne suffira pas bien entendu
que c'est un tout et qu'il ya toute une
chaîne pénale à réarmer
à l'issue du désarmement pénale dont
avait fait preuve
madame taubira sous le quinquennat
dernier le plan de construction de
prisons qui avaient été mises en oeuvre
sous le quinquennat nicolas sarkozy
avait été arrêté sur le quinquennat de
françois hollande et nous souhaitons
évidemment que de nouvelles
constructions de prison puisse avoir
lieu
non pas pour le principe ou pour le
plaisir d'en fermer mais tout simplement
parce que la société doit s'adapter à la
délinquance et emprisonner tous ceux qui
méritent de l'être pour protéger la
société de tous ceux qui ont aujourd'hui
considérer que les agressions la
commission de délits ou d'acte criminel
pouvait être excusés par cette culture
de l'excusé qui malheureusement à nîmes
trop de responsables publics de gauche
c'est un tout nous sommes aussi
d'ailleurs pour humaniser les conditions
de détention parce que nous savons très
bien que c'est par la construction de
nouvelles prisons que nous pourrons
aussi permettre l'encellulement
individuel pour ce qu'il souhaite
et cette question de l'humanisation des
conditions de détention avaient été
abordés déjà il ya plus de quinze ans de
cela par l'ancien médecin chef de la
prison de la santé véronique vasseur
avait fait l'objet de deux commission
denquête mais depuis pas grand chose n'a
été fait malheureusement et nous
souhaitons aussi bien entendu que
l'humanisation des conditions carcérales
puisse se faire parallèlement la
construction de nouvelles prisons et
encore une fois c'est pas
la construction de nouvelles prisons que
nous pourrons humaniser les conditions
de détention et c'est par la
construction de nouvelles prisons que
les prisons deviendront efficace josiah
voilà je vois là évoqué la délinquance a
évolué et effectivement c'est une
délinquance qui est de plus en plus
jeunes et de plus en plus violentes et
on le voit avec les attaques dont sont
victimes les policiers et face à cela
dans ce qu'on appelle certaines zones de
non droit la police de sécurité du
quotidien qui est finalement que le
recyclage du dispositif jospin de police
de proximité va se révéler inefficace
c'est plus d'autorité qu'il faut qu'il
faut pouvoir mettre en place et la peur
doit changer de camp la peur peut-être
du côté de ces délinquants qui sont de
plus en plus jeunes et de plus en plus
violents sur la sécurité routière le
premier ministre
donc a annoncé une baisse de 90 à 80
km/heure sur les axes secondaires donc
pour les nationales et départementales
en se basant sur sur sur les résultats
d'une expérimentation de deux années qui
ont été menées dans l'yonne et dans la
nièvre
nous aimerions avoir les résultats de
cette expérimentation nous demandons la
transparence sur ces résultats plusieurs
sénateurs ont fait cette demande et pour
le moment nous n'avons pas les résultats
de cette expérimentation
nous considérons que la sécurité
routière est un enjeu majeur la
mortalité sur sur les routes est un
enjeu majeur qui doit qui doit diminuer
très fortement mais mais pour cela il
nous semble que réduire exclusivement la
vitesse n'est pas le seul levier
il faut un traitement qui soit multi
factorielle avec notamment pour ne pas
abandonner les personnes qui sont en
zone rurale un véritable investissement
sûr sur la sécurité de ce réseau
secondaire et puis et puis une véritable
politique pour pouvoir améliorer l'état
des routes sur sur ces réseaux tout en
ayant une action sur la la consommation
de stupéfiants et d'alcool pour rappel
l'alcool et à 29% à l'origine
d'accidents mortels
donc nous demandons à voir véritablement
les eaux pures le plus rapidement
possible les résultats de cette
expérimentation est à ce que le
gouvernement est une action qui traite
tous les facteurs de la mortalité
routière
recoins d'actualité c'est celle qui
concerne l'éventuel transfert de
l'aéroport nantes atlantique vers notre
dame des landes
il s'agit pas ici pour nous de prendre
position
mais sur le principe mais de d'appeler
le gouvernement à faire respecter les
décisions populaires sous le dernier
quinquennat une consultation populaire a
été décidé par l'exécutif
elle a appelés aux urnes un million de
français c'était en juin 2016
le taux de participation a dépassé les
50% et la décision populaire a été nette
puisque le oui l'a emporté environ 55%
nous aimerions parce que nous
considérons qu'il est indispensable de
respecter la volonté populaire que le
gouvernement prenne en compte cette
consultation
plutôt que de multiplier les tables
rondes où les expertises comme elle est
en train de le faire en ce moment dans
une démocratie dans une république le
peuple c'est sacré et nous considérons
aussi que tous les plaisirs ont une fin
la plupart de ceux qui nous écoutent
nous regardons qui sont dans cette salle
n'était pas née lorsque la question du
transfert de cet aéroport vers notre
dame des landes a été posée cela fait
plus de cinquante ans que la question
est posée
l'action publique c'est écoutez c'est
réfléchir puis c'est décidé et c'est
faire respecter sa décision
c'est tranché et c'est mettre en oeuvre
il nous sommes convaincus que la
réhabilitation de l'action publique dans
le coeur des français
dépendra de la capacité des responsables
politiques à mettre en oeuvre lors
décision d'autant plus qu'elles sont
assorti d'une consultation populaire et
d'une sanction populaire au sens propre
du terme
la république ne doit donc pas avoir sur
notre dame des landes
la main qui tremble et elle ne dote pas
avoir la main qui tremble sur
l'évacuation quelle que soit la décision
prise par le gouvernement sur le
transfert ou non de l'aéroport de nantes
atlantique vers notre dame des landes
sur l'évacuation de cette zone occupée
par les 10 analystes qui est bien plus
malheureusement qu'une zone de non droit
qui est devenu une zone de tous les
droits
sauf pour la république une zone où
certains quelques-uns se sont arrogés
tous les droits
considérant qu'il pouvait légitimement
pester défier et piétiné la république
et ses principes les plus fondamentaux
comme les plus élémentaires
eh bien nous appelons le gouvernement à
ne pas avoir la main qui tremble et à
évacuer par la force le cette zone des à
dist il y a des moments où la force et
l'utilisation de la force légitime et
laisser cette zone comme ça a été trop
le cas par le passé
défier la république est un symbole de
l'impuissance publique qui est
aujourd'hui intolérable inacceptable et
auquel il faut mettre fin sans délai
donc d'un côté nous demandons à ce que
les décisions populaires soient
respectés c'est un principe
emmanuel macron ne peut pas vouloir
davantage comme il le dit lui-même
associé le peuple sur les questions
européennes et de l'autre s'asseoir sur
les décisions populaires sous prétexte
que la consultation de 2016 n'a pas été
de son fait
aujourd'hui il y à une décision
populaire elle doit être respectée
il ya une république y défier eh bien il
faut aujourd'hui sans délais mettre un
terme à cette zone de tous les droits
qui est totalement inadmissible sur le
territoire fin
voici ce que nous voulions vous dire sur
les différents points d'actualité de
rentrée je précise aussi que cette
rentrée sera fera l'objet d'une émission
vous le savez de laurent wauquiez sur
france 2 le jeudi 25 janvier ce sera sa
rentrée politique avec l'émission
politique mais surtout le 27 janvier le
samedi 27 janvier à la mutualité me
semble-t-il
nous aurons conseil national qui sera
évidemment le grand moment de rentrée
politique des républicains à l'occasion
duquel laurent wauquiez devant un
discours à la fois politique sur la
france mais aussi politique sur le
calendrier de travail des républicains
pour l'ensemble de l'année 2018
encore une fois l'année 2018 sera un
moment de production d'idées nouvelles
de préparation des élections européennes
qui sont évidemment les futures
échéances
le juin 2019 et de respect des
sensibilités nous avons des sensibilités
qui s'expriment au sein des républicains
tant mieux nous considérons que c'est
l'union qui fait la force et que c'est
aussi notre diversité qui nous enrichit
c'est à la fois une ligne politique que
nous devons mettre en place puis mettre
en oeuvre et en même temps un respect
des sensibilités et des convictions de
chacun
nous sommes riches de notre diversité
le parcours du renouvellement des
visages et des usages et nous sommes
aussi très fiers d'avoir aujourd'hui une
tête laurent wauquiez qui fort de sa
légitimité militante pourra incarner
l'opposition républicaine dont je
parlais au début de ce point presse et
qui évidemment plus que nécessaire dans
une démocratie
nous vous remercions
bonjour on a appris aujourd'hui que le
seuil des cent mille demandes d'asile
avait été atteint en 2010 est je voulais
savoir qu'elle était un votre réaction
et 2 ce que vous attendez du projet de
loi qui est en préparation et qui doit
être présenté d'ici quelques semaines
le projet de loi annoncé
nous n'avons pas lu donc évidemment
difficile de se prononcer de manière
officielle sur ce texte nous voyons en
revanche que dans le budget 2010 8 les
crédits alloués à l'aide médicale d'état
ont augmenté de plus de 100 millions
d'euros 110 millions d'euros et nous
avons observé aussi dans le projet de
loi de finances 2010 8 une soupe
budgétisation des centres de rétention
administrative
donc nous pointons d'ores et déjà un
décalage entre une fermeté apparente
d'après les premières indiscrétions sur
le projet de loi et de l'autre une
faiblesse manifeste qui s'est révélé
lors de la préparation du budget 2010 8
il faut évidemment que nous
différencions bien les réfugiés
politiques c'est à dire ceux qui
méritent d'être accueillis sur notre sol
puisque c'est notre tradition et c'est
notre honneur d'accueillir tous ceux qui
méritent de se voir accorder ce statut
de réfugié parce qu'ils sont pourchassés
dans leur pays pour leurs convictions
politiques ou parfois pour leur
orientation sexuelle ou pour leurs
convictions religieuses
de l'autre côté il y a les immigrés
économiques qui ne peuvent pas du tout
être traités de la même manière il
confondu avec ceux qui méritent de se
voir accorder le statut de réfugié
politique
et pour cela la droite c'est
souvent engagés en considérant que
l'immigration doit être réduite et
qu'elle doit surtout faire l'objet de
quotas d'immigration légale voté chaque
année par le parlement et qu'une
maîtrise très forte des flux migratoires
doit être mise en place
ce qui est très différent encore une
fois de la tradition qui fait notre
honneur de d'accueil des réfugiés
politiques
il va falloir bien sûr sur l'asile faire
en sorte de faire baisser de manière
considérable les délais de traitement
qui sont aujourd'hui bien trop long il
va falloir aussi surtout s'assurer que
ceux qui sont déboutés de leur demande
d'asile soit effectivement reconduits
sans délai dans leur pays d'origine
la meilleure manière d'accueillir ceux
qui le souhaitent et qui le mérite c'est
aussi d'être très ferme à l'égard de
tous ceux qui instrumentalisent le
régime de l'asile pour en réalité venir
à des fins économiques etc se sait cette
césure
il va bien falloir mettre en place et en
tout cas c'est ce que nous souhaiterons
officiellement au nom des républicains
au moment du débat sur le projet de loi
immigration qui viendra à cette année
parce que il y à tous ceux qui ne
respectent pas nos règles
nos lois et nos valeurs et qui ont
vocation à être reconduits dans leur
pays d'origine
et il y à tous ceux qui viennent
légalement ou qui viennent parce que ils
sont pourchassés dans leur pays
d'origine et qui eux mérite évidemment
d'être accueillis dignement
c'est à la fois le maintien de cette
tradition de d'accueil des réfugiés et
de l'autre cette fermeté nécessaire pour
mieux maîtriser les flux migratoires qui
doit être la politique voulue par les
républicains et nous l'espérons celle du
gouvernement mais les premiers signaux
qui ont été ceux du projet de loi de
finances 2010 8 nous inquiètent bien
évidemment
bonjour vous avez critiqué le projet de
monnaie macron d'un contrôle des faits
qui nous apprendra loi qui contrôlerait
avisera contrôle et etc nous est
aujourd'hui un sondage qui sort sur les
théories du complot qui montre qu'elles
sont qu'elle pénètre à ce fait des
françaises de manière assez importante
est ce qu'il n'ya pas quelque chose à
faire justement pour réussir à contrôler
l'expansion de sa théorie du complot
alors contrôler l'expansion de ces
théories du complot le complotisme
effectivement est de plus en plus
répandue notamment chez les jeunes alors
il faut lutter à là dessus mais je ne
crois pas que ce soit avec cette ce
projet sur le contrôle des fake news qui
peut qui peut porter préjudice à la
liberté d'expression
à quel moment on est face à une fake
news qui décide que c'est une fake news
enfin il ya beaucoup de questions qu'il
faut qu'il faut qu'il faut soulever et
il faut y aller véritablement pourquoi
avec la main qui tremble
c'est un sujet sensible qui va falloir
si si le président va jusqu'au bout de
son projet traité véritablement avec
beaucoup beaucoup de précautions parce
qu'on peut en essayant de contrôler la
liberté d'expression on peut à petit à
petit si elles tombent entre de
mauvaises mains a glissé vers vers les
régimes autoritaires et la république et
la démocratie doivent doivent se
prévaloir de cela la liberté
d'expression doit être totalement
protégé
donc nous sommes extrêmement extrêmement
vigilants sur sur sur ce projet pour
faire et qu est ce que tu as dit les
républicains seront effectivement très
vigilants très soucieux parce que très
attachée au principe quasi absolu de la
liberté d'expression je pense que c'est
nécessaire que nous le rappelions bien
sûr monsieur que nous sommes pas aux
républicains pour les faits que nous
bien sûr que
il y à des fausses nouvelles qui le sont
objectivement et qui mérite d'être
sanctionné
il y a d'ailleurs un arsenal législatif
qui existe déjà
il y à la diffamation qui permet lorsque
vous dites des choses fausses qui
atteint qui atteignent l'honneur d'une
personne d'être sanctionné et il faut
qu'il qu'elles le soient effectivement
durement bien sûr que nous pouvons tous
ensemble réfléchir à la diffusion de
fausses nouvelles et à une meilleure
manière de les sanctionner
mais il ne doit pas non plus y avoir une
vérité d'état il doit pas y avoir un
gouvernement qui dira aux journalistes
ou dire à tous ceux qui sont attachés à
la liberté d'expression ce qui est dit
cible et ce qui ne l'est plus faisons
déjà respecter les lois existantes
plutôt que d'en inventer de nouvelles
pour faire plaisir à quelques uns
nous sommes autant qu emmanuel macron
attaché à la vérité des faits
mais nous aimerions que ce soit avant
tout une responsabilité individuelle et
que ce soit avant tout l'arsenal
législatif existant qui puisse être
concrètement appliquée plutôt que de
communiquer sur défectueuse parce que
comme l'a dit lidia c'est la définition
même de ce qui constituera au sens légal
une fac news de ce qui la constitue
rappaz qui deviendra un casse tête
parce que où s'arrête la fecq news où
s'arrête la liberté d'expression on peut
en discuter mais avouez quand même que
ce jeu là qui consiste à venir
limiter de manière forte le principe
même de la liberté d'expression est
particulièrement dangereux générés par
europe 1 deux petites questions
avez vous une réaction concernant les
tweets de ryan d art nouveau
porte-parole la république en marche et
seconde question êtes vous satisfait du
travail
la commission nationale des comptes de
campagne on a été consternée de
découvrir que le porte parole de la
république en marche alors qu'il était
étudiant à l'ena utiliser ce type de
vocabulaire est pratiquée l'injure
publique sur les réseaux sociaux ce qui
nous a consterné c'est qu'après après la
députée du nouveau monde
donc qui fait payer les visites à
l'assemblée nationale celui qui s'en
prend à un opposant le frappant à coups
de casque décidément le casting
macron est quand même un petit peu
douteux donc cesser ces insultes qui qui
s'en prennent à des femmes en parlant
d'elle comme de de pouffiasses je
pense que ryan sesa peut être aussi
faire partie de la campagne balances ton
port parce que c'est pas une façon de
parler une personnalité publique c'est
ce type d'injures et le silence de
castaner et quand même assourdissant et
très très gênant pour le moment on n'a
pas vu de réaction très forte
on aimerait avoir des sanctions ne
serait ce que pour respecter cette
fameuse moralisation de la vie publique
a été promise par marc emmanuel macron
et puis cette exemplarité que
brandissent sans arrêt les membres de la
république en marche donc c'est assez
consternant quand même de voir que c'est
ce porte parole et puis à tant d'autres
personnalités de de la république en
marche ont ce type de vocabulaire fleuri
et eon l'injure aussi facile et nous
appelons quand même à à des sanctions et
et je dirais à adé à une condamnation un
peu plus forte l'excusé avancée de la
jeunesse ne ne tient pas il était je le
rappelle élèves à l'ena et avait plus de
22 ou 23 ans donc on est assez conscient
de ce qu'on fait de ce conte écrire à
cet âge là
rectif n'est pas de donner des leçons de
morale à qui que ce soit d'ailleurs je
déteste en donner aux autres parce que
je déteste recevoir moi même mais plutôt
que d'appeler à là démission de ce
nouveau porte parole
nous l'appelons juste à la décence à la
décence et à la décence de tous les
membres du gouvernement lorsqu'il
s'exprime sur lui puisque dire comme
madame p nikola fait que c'était une
erreur de jeunesse alors que lorsqu'il a
écrit de telles insultes
il avait effectivement 23 ans a été
élève à l'ena qui quand même une école
de la haute fonction publique
c'est indécent et nous considérons qu'il
y à des insultes politiques qui sont
imprescriptibles
il n'y a pas eu la d'erreur de jeunesse
il y à des insultes politiquement
imprescriptibles on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui publiquement
lorsqu'on aspire à être un responsable
politique pouvoir insulté de pouffiasses
et d'autres termes objectivement
insultant d autres responsables le
public ou d'ailleurs des citoyens quels
qu'ils soient et quels que soient leurs
responsabilités donc nous appelons à la
décence c'est à christophe castaner d'en
prendre toutes les conséquences on n'est
pas là pour s'ingérer dans les affaires
internes de la république en marche et
en tout cas imaginez un instant ce que
ça aurait été si ç'avait été l'un de
nous porte parole aux responsables ou
membres de l'équipe dirigeante des
républicains et de la droite
républicaine qui avait fait cela j'ai
l'impression que les réactions auraient
pu être bien supérieure et que les
appels à la démission aurait été
automatique de la part du nouveau monde
finalement les courbes entre le nouveau
monde et l'ancien monde semble s'être
croisés assez rapidement sur la
commission des comptes de campagne
moi je n'ai